you're doing stuff and it's not working
this might be why i was starting my
first gym and someone told me that i
should put flyers out and so i did put
flyers out lo and behold no one called
me except for one guy who said that i'd
ding this car i met with the guy who
told me to do the flyer so i was like
hey man i did the flyers they didn't
work and he's like well what was your
test size and i was like well what do
you mean he was like well how many did
you put out the test i was like well i
put 300 out he said dude i don't even
test under 5000. whoa and that was when
my entire paradigm shifted around the
amount of effort that was required to be
successful i was doing the right thing
but i was doing way way way too little i
see that pattern in myself and so many
other entrepreneurs who are starting out
they're trying to figure out how to post
content how to run ads how to do sales
calls and they do two or five or they do
it for a week and they're like oh it's
not working when the people who've been
doing this game for a long time are
talking in decades not days